nous sommes ce soir une famille unie
rassemblée pour ce moment important
après nos échéances internes et après
avoir réuni tout à l'heure ici même
l'équipe dirigeante de notre famille
politique une équipe qui incarne cette
volonté d'unité de rassemblement que
nous avons partagé avec Bruno retaillod
et avec Aurélien Pradier que je remercie
pour leur engagement pour la façon dont
la campagne interne s'est déroulée sans
aucune difficulté et dont nous avons pu
ensemble constituer cette équipe
dirigeante qui est aujourd'hui je crois
représentatif de notre famille dans sa
diversité dans sa richesse de ces
territoires de ses sensibilités de ces
personnalités
cette famille politique nous l'aimons
cette famille politique je l'aime
passionnément et précisément car une
famille politique est bien davantage
comme partie c'est tout à la fois un
passé et un avenir partagé de grandes
figures mais aussi de grandes conquêtes
l'implosion tant de fois annoncé par
tant de commentateurs avisés n'a pas eu
lieu et je leur dis elle n'aura jamais
lieu jamais lassé de se tromper il nous
disait mort et enterré nous sommes bien
vivants rappelons à ceux qui prédisent
notre disparition tant il la souhaite
qu'une famille qui dispose de 62 députés
de 142 sénateurs qui préside des
milliers de collectivités départements
région commune qui préside de multiples
intercommunalités qui comptent près de
95000 militants est un parti plus vivant
bien vivant et fort de ses atouts et de
ses richesses un parti vivant fort de
tant de personnalité expérimentés qui
demain si la France nous accorde de
nouveaux sa confiance peuvent gouverner
sans attendre avec le sérieux
l'expertise la compétence le talent
l'efficacité que le gouvernement d'un
grand pays exige et nous le rappellerons
avec force dans les jours qui viennent
avec la désignation d'un contre
gouvernement
notre raison d'être c'est le service de
la nation
l'intérêt général du pays qui nous
dépasse tous ce qui nous réunit au-delà
de nos victoires mais aussi de nos
échecs de nos espoirs ou de nos bois
c'est ce qui nous engage aujourd'hui à
écrire à ouvrir une nouvelle page de
notre histoire en apprenant de nos
réussites comme de nos revers en dépit
des tempêtes que nous avons connues nous
sommes debout et grâce à vous grâce à
ces militants de la France qui œuvrent
avec vous avec nous et qui demeure
contre vents et marées fidèle à leur
conviction nous voulons encore et plus
que jamais être utile au peuple de
France
moderniser et dynamiser notre partie
c'est respecter nos adhérents aussi nous
devrons en cela nous engager à faire
deux un rouage essentiel de nos débats
et chaque adhérent doit savoir que sa
carte n'est pas simplement un petit
morceau de plastique mais bien au-delà
cette carte elle offre et elle doit
offrir plus que jamais la possibilité de
participer activement à cette
reconstruction à cette réflexion que
nous allons mener au plus loin pour être
plus que jamais je le répète
utile à la France face aux vacarme des
démagogies et de leurs promesses sans
lendemain les Français ont besoin de
nous ils ont besoin de nos valeurs
valeurs d'autorité de liberté d'identité
de souveraineté face mes chers amis à
l'impuissance de ce gouvernement la
seule alternative sérieuse est à
la seule alternative sérieuse c'est nous
c'est avec nous que les Français
parviendront à rétablir l'ordre dans
leur ville et préserver leur campagne de
la
contagion de la violence c'est avec nous
que les Français parviendront à défendre
cette identité nationale qui est tant de
fois a permis à notre pays d'inspirer le
monde entier durant tant de siècles par
son esprit des lumières par la liberté
des valeurs universelles qui se sont
propagés dans le monde et en Europe
chère Michel Barnier en te remerciant
d'avoir accepté aussi de porter dans
cette équipe le nos relations
internationales c'est avec nous que les
Français parviendront à se libérer du
carcan de temps de normes et de
l'asphyxie de tant de taxes et d'impôts
c'est avec nous que les Français
parviendront à retisser des mailles
épaisses le tissu de notre solidarité
nationale notamment envers tous les
accidents de la vie et c'est avec nous
que les Français parviendront à
retrouver cette valeur essentielle la
dignité du travail la dignité par le
travail alors que la gauche défendent
désormais le droit à la paresse nous
défendons le droit à la dignité du
travail et si pour sauver notre système
de retraite il faudra demander aux
Français de travailler un peu plus nous
exigerons du gouvernement qui leur
garantissent de travailler mieux mes
amis le temps de l'offensive est venu le
déclin que nous vivons n'est pas une
fatalité et nous devons rappeler sans
cesse que la France demeure la plus
ferme et la plus précieuse de nos
espérances Unis déterminée dans la
clarté la cohérence la responsabilité
animée par un courage qui ne se lasse
jamais nous devons être le parti des
espérances françaises
l'espérance du renouveau l'espérance du
redressement somme toute l'espérance que
la France reste la France avec vous j'y
consacrerai toutes mes forces toute mon
énergie toute ma passion toute ma
patience je sais que nous mènerons
toujours ensemble dans le respect de
chacun le combat pour le triomphe des
valeurs qui font notre unité des valeurs
qui peuvent être et qui seront demain
l'avenir de notre pays car ce pays n'a
pas fini de susciter l'admiration du
monde